unemployment claimants who were worried
about a delayed payment woke up to some
really good news those payments did come
through
joe mohler is live outside deter offices
joe with a positive update
yeah that's right we'll get to that in
just a moment here now many were worried
about when this payment would exactly
come through
yesterday dieter told us it could take
up to 48 hours so
as you can imagine people are happy to
see this money come through overnight
now on monday deters said
there was an issue with their system
causing a delay in payments
they did not say what the issue was
exactly many were hoping to get the
missing payment by tomorrow after deters
said it would take a few days but for
most it came today
also some claimants not all are telling
me their lost wages assistance fifth
week payment came in there are still
some that are missing that and they are
still frustrated
we spoke to melissa herman who got her
payment from this week she worries now
about future payments
definitely a sense of relief kind of
like a weight off my shoulders
really scary because christmas is coming
and
i mean it it's
really nerve-racking
now we also want to update you on a
story we shared yesterday elijah not was
worried when his weekly payment did not
come in this week he was days from
having
his power shut off days away that is
after my story aired
a wonderful eight news now viewer
contacted me offering to pay
the father of five's 239 dollar electric
bill
i got them in contact with each other
while our viewer wanted to remain
anonymous
knott says his wife and grandma who
lives next door were in shock
they both cried it put tears in my eyes
and
that's hard to do i mean i'm pretty much
a hardened
ex-military vet i was a medic so i've
seen a lot of stuff and
learned how to internalize but even i
had tears last night because
i couldn't believe the generosity of
somebody who didn't know me who just
wanted to reach out and help
he says this will help him buy more
christmas gifts for his children
the anonymous donor says they canceled
their usual holiday events due to the
virus and had the extra money to help
now the viewer also did contact me
saying they were going to help
in another way as well so that's still
to come but
this is just a nice story we want to
share here during the holiday